thank you Frank and thank you all for
being here
well here it is fear not I begin by
saying fear not because anxiety seems to
be a feature of discourse about
technologies of reading technologies of
intellectual interpretation the locus
classic us for this is in Victor Hugo's
notre dame de perry englished as the
hunchback of notre dam in which at one
point the wicked Archdeacon holds up one
of the newfangled printed books
brandishing it against the sky and the
spires of nutria DOM and cries out this
will kill that I remember that story
because it was repeated in 1994 in the
strangest country I have ever visited
San Marino in landlocked in Italy a
country which lives it turns out on its
postage stamps and crossbows at a
conference at which on the future of the
book at which the closing discourse was
given by umberto eco and echoed shows
that as the theme of his talk
brandishing what was then called a
laptop I think it weighed about 14
pounds in 1994 and a paperback to book
and said now will this kill that the
power of technologies of reading to
change society's is a theme of much
modern scholarship and we've now found
ourselves living in a time in which
change seems to be happening around us
and we brandish this change in this form
of cultural icon and artifact having
spent a fair amount of time thinking
about that history and about the role of
electronic technology in classrooms and
publishing and scholarship when this
thing fell into my hand a few months ago
I said I had better discipline myself
not simply to start using it but to
thinking about it and seeing what I can
learn from it and I'm here today to
share some of the fruits of that
conversation the first fear not that I
should emphasize is this is not going to
be a product review of the Kindle Cicero
was famous for developing the rhetorical
tactic of the priority 0 the passing by
the making no mention of things I mean
his form it would say I make no mention
of your accounts in the Caymans I make
no mention of your bastard children i'm
here today to talk about your policies i
will try to make as little mention as
possible
the quirks and foibles of this
particular device and that I think is
only fair because this device is one
device in a history that rapidly evolves
this is already three months old the
iPad will be released in a few weeks and
all the blogosphere is alert to what
Bezos will do next with the kindle in
order to compete with the ipad and so
forth so many of the things one can
complain about anna device of this kind
will in fact go away in a short period
of time up so i will not talk about the
funny screen i will not talk about the
weirdest choice of all it seems to me
making the back surrounding frame white
there by emphasizing that the screen
isn't really white in other words my
surmises of the screen if the surround
were black you might actually think the
screen was white but when you make it a
flat white now the screen is a kind of
dull grey against which the black
characters appear I will not complain
about the funny chiclet keyboard down
here at the bottom that can only be done
one letter at a time and then usually
wrongly I might complain slightly and
this is under the category of crippled
functionality about the fact that the
search engine which they offer is not as
smart as Google's and is therefore
unforgiving of typographical errors
until I used this in fact I had not
realized just how sloppy I was becoming
about spelling because Google can always
figure out what I really meant to say
and give me good answers in spite of it
one letter off with this and you get
absolutely zero results and you have to
go back and figure out where the
chicklets went wrong for you there is
other crippled functionality it does
have network connection it has the most
useless web browser that I have ever
seen but it's easy to assume that
sometime in the not-too-distant future
that browser will be improved so that
the Kindle can continue to compete
willow devices I will not complain about
the battery life it's one of the few
devices whose battery life I will not
complain about it really does last a
very long time
and that's good news what I will
complain about however is my travel load
in which now when I take a trip of more
than a few days and find myself checking
into a room and let's say New Delhi I
now find that I am crawling around on
the floor trying to match electrical
plug adapters to electrical plugs for no
fewer than six different rechargeable
devices at one time the notion that this
now has added itself as the sixth does
not please me in its own right it's a
reminder that we live in a space and
with a bag full of gadgets each of which
comes with an incompatible plug adapter
whatever to go with it and attention
must be paid on the train today I
discovered that my blackberry hadn't
been properly plugged in overnight so
I'm now on blackberry rationing today
and some of you who do indeed know me
recognize what an austere discipline
that is for for me I pass over all those
things and do not talk about them I
would almost pass over a few other
things and meant to pass over them but I
find that I cannot it is a feature of
this device that it takes only
proprietary texts there is a way to
download document files in PDF files i
will simply say i haven't made that work
very well for me so far but essentially
it will only acquire book formats if
they have been converted by amazon or if
they come from amazon's kindle store and
so I will let myself complain about the
extraordinarily limited selection of
titles that are available this is even a
consumer warning when Amazon tells you
that there are 300 or 400 thousand
titles available for the kindle what
they are not telling you is there are
really about thirty thousand titles
available for the kindle of things that
you and I might call books and then
there is an almost infinite supply of
shovelware that is to say digitized out
of copyright online texts which various
entrepreneurs some of them perhaps Yale
students have put together in a form to
upload amazon to sell to you for a
dollar 99 or 299 there's an almost
infinite number of copies of some
classic works of literature available in
this price range and that's the point at
which i will say that the metadata that
come with these texts in the kindle
store is beyond horrible
one of the first things I did when I got
my device was tell myself that I needed
to download to it an unabridged copy of
the greatest novel ever written count of
monte cristo you know that count of
monte cristo was a challenge to find an
unabridged form in american bookstores
and libraries anyway but it turned out
to be a triple challenge to find in the
in the kindle store there were at least
a dozen different versions of the count
of monte cristo and no reliable data to
suggest what kind of edition what kind
of translation or whether you were
getting the whole thing or not the only
way to know whether you got the whole
thing was to spend the dollar
ninety-nine on it I could afford it
download it and then see how many
locations each kindle text has a certain
number of locations and if the number
was really big then it's probably
unabridged that's an amateurish way to
know what sort of object you are buying
it makes me nostalgic for the old bound
volumes of books and print that used to
be behind the counter at the bookstore
where at least you had reliable
bibliographical double dia graphical
data but I pass over these things and I
do not mention them either except
perhaps to linger on my curious
discovery of my price resistance i'm
willing to pay about a dollar
ninety-nine for anything so far i
haven't paid more than 999 for anything
and i can't bring myself to spend more
than 999 and i'll spend the 999 and I'll
say a couple of things I've bought in a
while when it's not available otherwise
I went looking for a novel I wanted to
read it turns out to be out of print and
unavailable except an old used copies
for 999 on the Kindle what the heck it's
not a novel i much care about but I
spend in fact my first week in
possession of the thing trying to
convince myself to buy a new hardcover
book an important book the one that has
held me up for the longest is Orhan
Tomic's new novel the Museum of
innocence I'll come back to that I
cannot persuade myself to buy that for
the kindle this is not a rational
reaction I'm simply reporting a physical
fact about myself when facing the screen
that says by Museum of innocence now it
doesn't happen and I can't very well
explained why except that there's
something wrong
with the price and value equation what I
do want to talk about however are the
reading practices that are predicted
rehearsed prescribed by this device in
this kind of device tools leave traces
one of my colleagues on that Library of
Congress study that Frank referred to
taught us that after ISM which is to say
that whatever it is you use to do your
work leaves traces on the work itself
leaves traces on the way you do your
work many sorts of technologies and
structures predict rehearse and impose
forms of behavior upon us this podium
behind which I am standing imposes a
certain kind of authority relationship
in this room it was designed to do so it
does reasonably well I learned this one
time when we were trying to design a new
classroom in a building that had been
remodeled in the early days of network
technology and I said no no don't
believe all the plugs in the wall put
the plugs for power and network in the
floor in the middle of the room so that
devices can be on the table on the
seminar table I had seen a room before
that in which the plugs were all in the
wall and professors teaching in the room
spent a lot of time doing this and I had
no particular appetite for doing that
well it was complicated with expensive
putting power on the floor cost more
than putting power on the wall but we
were stubborn we persisted we got that
we got into the room after it had been
remodeled about half the size of this
but this shape and as soon as we sat
down at the table we realized that the
people who had done the task still
understood what kind of pedagogy we must
want to employ in the room the power
jacks in the network jacks were all up
at one end of the table where hair
professor could use them rather than in
the middle where there could be any more
democratic access to them and her
professor was required to stand at the
front of the room by the blackboard when
this hair professor actually wanted to
sit at the other end of the table with
the blackboard at the opposite end the
students between and a more collegial
and discussion based form of teaching
going on devices and technologies
predict behavior this device predicts
behavior when I think about this device
and its predictions and its impositions
as a scholar a working scholar in the
humanities
history and literature and culture then
I start running up into the practices
that I cannot employ the Kindle allows
you to annotate text for example but by
annotate text what it means is that you
may choose to highlight a body of text
or you may choose to attach a note to a
body of text it's rather like the
comment feature in microsoft word for
example but what it then does not allow
you to do is rifle through your notes
rearrange them extract them put them
someplace else three-by-five cards were
more complicated devices onto which to
transfer the information but vastly more
functional as devices for sorting and
using information and somewhere between
the three by five card and the Kindle I
realize I've developed practices in in
the internet world and on my computer's
that allow me to cut and paste that
allow me to reorganize to take
quotations that I've put in my notes and
plop them directly into my text without
without in accuracy I may be the only
person anywhere on the blogosphere who
keeps his personal blog entirely secret
from the rest of the world because it's
not for you it's for me it's the place I
take notes it's under a pseudonym if you
it's not searchable if you ever found it
which would be by accident you wouldn't
know who put it together but in any
internet-connected machine in the world
except this one that I find myself
sitting I can cut and paste I can make
notes I can put them in what we now
think fashionably of as the cloud and
the notes follow me around wherever
wherever I go not perfectly functional
more functional than three-by-five cards
vastly more functional than what this
device allows this device is not
friendly to that scholarly business of
annotation it is also not friendly to
complex documents and I don't know that
I ever would have said until I got a
device like this but I insist on reading
complex documents but I do insist on
reading complex documents I need not
only footnotes footnotes or clunky and
the Kindle you have to click on the
footnote call and wait a moment while it
goes and fishes out just the note
displays it on screen then you have to
hit the back
button to go back to where you are even
the hideous notes in the back of printed
books are easier to use than than that
technology but I also need maps and
diagrams I need to flip back and forth I
need to be able to put my fingers in a
page i need to be able to put two things
side by side sometimes i need to be able
to have the text running down one side
of the page and a translation down the
other none of these things can i do in
this space this is in many respects the
old papyrus roll brought back to life in
which you begin scrolling at the
beginning and the natural way to read
the object is to keep scrolling and keep
scrolling and keep scrolling until you
finally come to the end and find the
colophon the colophon was a greek word
meaning be kind rewind which was used in
all the papyrus scrolls of ancient times
the kindle drives you away from
nonlinear access to text which has been
a feature of the Codex book for 500
years now and back towards something
more like scrolling scrolling scrolling
scrolling at one point I found myself
recalling from my doctoral dissertation
days here sitting in a room not far from
this spot scrolling through a negative
microfilm of a German dissertation that
proposed to explore whether there was a
relation between two particular works of
ancient literature this was the one
where I discovered on about page 20 that
I had a nagging suspicion and had to
make the cost-benefit decision of shall
I scroll all the way through now to read
the conclusion to see where this is
going knowing I'll then have to scroll
all the way back I did I got all the way
through to the end and I found the last
line of the dissertation in German said
and so we have shown conclusively that
there is no relationship between these
two works of literature fortunately then
I could do the automated rewind and be
done with it the same kind of
cost-benefit decision imposes itself
upon you when you read this device I
have needs as a scholar I need
particular standard works of reference
particular standard works of texts I
can't accept substitutes I might be able
to go online and I confess I do it and
find badly edited and train
scribe Latin texts and something called
the Latin library I even use Wikipedia I
try not to use it more than fifty or a
hundred times a day because I am a
serious scholar but I need for scholarly
purposes to find other works of
reference other documents other
particular devices I've spent an
inordinate amount of time in the last
two days tracking down editions of a
standard old history of Latin literature
published originally in 1890 reproduced
in 1927 I discover that i can find full
text in google books of the night 1890
version I've compared and contrasted I
still want the 1927 fortunately I found
a copy for fifteen dollars on abebooks
and so that will come and sit next to my
Kindle I wish were in my Kindle I wish I
had it electronically I do not let me
pause there and say that in describing
some of these shortcomings of the device
and the practices of the device I'm well
aware that they are not all be laid at
the doorstep of the vendor the
manufacturer there are challenges in the
intellectual property environment in
which we work that make it difficult for
us to have access to all the things that
we know we could easily have access to
on another day in another place I find I
am supposed to give a talk in which I
talk about the google book settlement
and i would say here only that i find it
perplexing that there has been as little
gratitude shown to google as there has
been for spending 250 or 300 million
dollars digitizing books and for finding
some way in which we will be able to get
access to electronic representations of
literally hundreds of thousands to
millions of books I might like a
different settlement I might like them
freer I might like them cheaper I might
like a bunch of things but I hope I at
least remember to say thank you
somewhere along the way Google Books
horrible as a metadata maybe is
but I need standard works I need
specific additions I don't just need a
copy of The Count of Monte Cristo if I'm
writing about the count of monte cristo
I probably want a first edition or
representative edition of the first
edition done by the appropriate scholars
with appropriate care and attention and
that's because books talk to each other
sterling library and the places like it
or temples of that kind of conversation
I often feel when the books are talking
to each other that I'm really a
spectator or only one of the
participants in the conversation that's
going on among the many artifacts that
are upon my desk this device is designed
for me and one book to encounter each
other and to make of each other the most
that we can I can do things with that
but I can't do all the things that I've
been trained to do I can't do all the
things that I want to do I will
acknowledge that there is one supreme
virtue to this object it can hold a lot
of stuff I have no idea how much stuff
it can hold i'm pretty sure i haven't
come anywhere close to filling it up yet
i could load it up i could load it up i
could load it up so what have I in fact
done with it well I can take you through
the thought processes that have put in
it what gets in it first I said when I
got this for Christmas well here I am on
holiday doing something that in my
advancing years I do more frequently
which is reading ancient literature in
translation I'm a classicist I read lots
of ancient literature in Greek and Latin
but there are works that I know I'm
never going to go back to work on again
seriously that I still love in one form
or another and when traveling and
particularly on long trips with little
access to books I have found over the
last few years that the Odyssey the
Iliad Herodotus this time it was through
siddity xin Crawley's old translation a
fine piece of work lovely to read lovely
to enjoy I had the everyman library
version the everyman library like the
American modern library was in its way
the kindle of its day compact access to
classic literature so i downloaded i
found it took some work i downloaded
through siddha tease the good news the
bad news is that i got the text the good
news is that i kept reading the text the
bad news
is I still haven't quite finished
through cities I've got a couple of
books to go come back to that I then
went and had my voyage of discovery
finding the count of monte cristo that
was successful at various odd moments
i've read a few chapters here and there
the plot of Count of Monte Cristo has
few surprises left for me but it's been
a good many years since I read the whole
thing I think the last time I read the
whole thing was in fact here in a month
when I was supposed to be studying for
my doctor'll general examinations but
was reading do my instead with effort I
say I found him I then said so maybe
what I will do is read long works in
snippets at idle moments for self
edification so there then tumbled into
the machine montagnes essays in an old
translation followed by the anatomy of
melancholy a perfectly wonderful sort of
book that I've read in and around and up
one side of and down the other for many
years never read all the way through I
then realized that I needed to see if I
could find the funniest book ever
written to have in my in my Kindle and I
did that's three men in a boat by Jerome
K Jerome to say nothing of the dog but
that's another story then I began to
think so perhaps biblical texts how
about the Septuagint how about the Latin
Vulgate hop out the King James Version
with great effort I found a reliable
King James Version I think my bookmark
in that is somewhere around Potiphar
wife and I haven't been back to that in
some in some weeks now I also found a
great many highly unreliable biblical
texts along the way the only greek text
of the New Testament I could find was
one which essentially has been
rejiggered to make it compatible with
the King James Version because we all
know that God wrote the King James
Version and menthol other versions to be
compatible with that I downloaded a
sample from that and delete it as fast
as I can I can't find much of the Latin
Bible except the psalter so I found that
well my noble idea that I would have
this around with me and at serene and
wistful moments I would read a few pages
of Montagne or
or or robert burton hasn't actually
worked in the last couple of months
interesting for a practice the value I
say of this the unmistakable virtue is
that you can have lots and lots and lots
of that stuff if on the other hand
you're reading practices don't make you
go back to that stuff then it's not
quite clear exactly what value is there
there's a little bit of what has been
described in this for me as the ipod
phenomenon where you load up the ipod
with all of your favorite music and then
realize that one reason your favorite
radio station is your favorite radio
station is they play something besides
your favorite music and you actually
hear something new from time to time
whereas on your ipod you need to stop
and think about whether there's
something new and go out and look for it
in order for there to be something new
and meanwhile if you're me you're
beginning to get a little tired of
Mahler just now but there's a lot of
Muller on my iPod alright in a way this
has become for me the functional
equivalent traveling with me everywhere
I go of my bedside table at home now my
bedside table at home is a particular
kind of reading device it is a place
where good intentions are piled most of
those good intentions with bookmarks
about halfway through them periodically
because the the bedside table cannot
hold an infinite quantity of text there
needs to be a rueful encounter of good
intentions with some sluicing out in
some removal so that new good intentions
may be piled on top of the old one
especially when some of them are copies
of The New Yorker that are slippery and
things keep falling off on the floor
there is value but I'm not entirely sure
of the value since I went on myself
edification campaign I have been more
prudent about what not what I haven't
acquired and I have in fact bought by
actual count five books real books all
of them under ten dollars so one is a
new novel by John Banville called the
infinities I've never been really sold
on Banville but on the other hand this
is a novel in which greek gods appear in
more or less contemporary ireland as
characters in the novel and i'm working
on paganism just at the moment so i was
curious to see what he did and the
kindle version is cheaper than the new
cover which is the only other way in
which I can find it so what the heck
that has the distinction of being the
first book that I think I have actually
read all the way through from cover to
cover however at a rather high rate of
speed and I don't think I could pass a
very detailed quiz on the contents am I
also read Luke menands new book the
marketplace of ideas it's a skinny
little book of four essays about the
state of higher education it's the sort
of book that goes home and gets on the
bedside table and probably does get
skimmed most of the way through before
it goes back to where it came from I
probably should have gotten that from a
library but instead once again cheaper
than the new hardcover and there was
something satisfying about being able to
bring it home read it and delete it and
i will say that deleting books on the
kindle if you have not had this
experience is far less guilt ridden than
throwing away a physical book i'm not
sure how the two activities actually
differ from one another but i feel no
guilt whatsoever when i hit the delete
button on the on the kindle i'm now
purchased three more one is a scholarly
book i will forbear from mentioning it
but it is an expensive scholarly book
newly published which i am sure that I
will not like I am sure that I will not
read it from cover to cover but having
it in my possession for 999 so that I
can leave through it source through it
have an idea what's going on and go back
to it from time to time cus a little bit
spit a little bit fuss and fume a bit
and then at some point indeed have the
pleasure and satisfaction of hitting the
Delete key on that particular title is
also an attractive prospect now to look
forward to there are two more novels
that have now arrived their novels of a
kind which are related to my day job
novels of ancient Rome won a mystery one
a thriller robert harris and stephen
sailor these are very popular books very
well done i have a particular problem
with them as i had with the TV series
aroma which is that i can't read them
without feeling like i'm at work and
murder mysteries and thrillers aren't
supposed to feel like work I have an
idea that I will again skim through them
and one of the reasons I will skim
through them is built into the device if
you've not seen one this is what you get
and there are the buttons that say next
page
and when you are reading anything you
can sit and click and the next page
displays about as fast as you see that
flash of black what I discover is that
indeed with that and with only about 150
to 200 words visible on the screen at
one time I can pick up speed I can zoom
sue through some things well the scholar
in me is happy to get through content at
a high rate of speed and very unhappy to
get through content at a high rate of
speed because I don't read content when
I am being a scholar I pay more
attention to the things that sit in
front of me I think the functions of the
device are better accorded to a certain
kind of as we say nowadays ludic reading
reading for pleasure that is to say the
kind of reading i impute to other people
reading murder mysteries on railroad
trains I'm sure I do a much better job
of reading the murder mysteries and they
do but they are not me so they are
simply reading in a in a mindless way
but even if I think of this for ludic
reading it falls short of some of my
standards when every book is the same
size and shape looks the same feels the
same click click click there's something
missing this is not a high intellectual
cultural value that is missing but
there's something that I'm used to that
is missing I am used to books being
different I am used to each one having a
different feel a different size a
different shape I know the satisfaction
of leafing through a slender volume of
poetry the do we know elegies are one
kind of a book and the count of monte
cristo is a very different kind of book
in here they are both click click click
with a little slider bar going across
the bottom of the screen and the
difference is the slider bar goes faster
when there are fewer pages that doesn't
feel the same the page size is a problem
for me too few words too many clicks too
much speed of clicking too much speed of
reading I realize that the practice I
see emerging for myself is not so much
ludic reading as ludic ludic reading
that is to say the kind of reading in
which i am a consumer of information i
am a consumer of a processed item the
things i am reading in here feel to me
now like velveeta not
like cheese and I will acknowledge that
I eat Velveeta from time to time but i
will also acknowledge that Velveeta is
not cheese I also then realize one more
thing literally just last night as I was
packing up to come here I never read
this at home it's only a travel
accessory because at home there are I
hesitate to think a lot of other things
I could be reading a lot of other
enticements to my attention and when I
look at this object it feels like one
thing whereas all the other books on all
the shelves and all the pile on the
bedside table and all the pile by the
chair in the living room and all the
pile on the table in the living room
while on my desk and the ones out on the
kitchen table and all the other ones at
the office are many many more and some
part of the pleasure of ludic reading is
the pleasure of going shopping and
browsing among the books with which you
have surrounded yourself in order to
find the one that fits just right for
now maybe I can learn someday how to
find the book in here that fits just
right for right now I haven't done that
yet and I don't quite know how to train
myself to do it well I come to the end
of those reflections and pull back and
try to make sense of this device as a
whole and when I do that that I made for
myself the discovery that surprises me
most about this device it may be too
obvious for others but it was a
revelation for me and that is that first
in ways I have outlined this device
allows me to engage in a very selected
and limited set of reading practices
there are a lot of other kinds of
reading that I know how to do that I
care about doing that I want to do and I
want to be able to do everywhere I go
but then I had the revelation it's not
just that it's a limited set of
practices all of the practices this
device allows our old practices they are
practices of linear reading of a flat
text that has been downloaded from
someplace else you may read it as
rapidly as possible you may leave back
and forward through it but there's
nothing innovative about the kind of
reading you engage in the device is
innovative on multiple levels it's a
gadget you can make it this flat you can
give it this much battery life you can
download
text suet in a matter of seconds all
that feels like innovation but the
reading practices are so limited a
subset of forms of reading that it
almost feels like a parody of what
reading is like or could be there's no
innovation in this device what would
innovation look like well one form of
innovation would be to give me good
indices where I could begin the book at
the index and click on the page numbers
in the index going and looking for
things starting from the back forward a
good index is a beautiful thing at a
book I've read many of them I enjoy them
it's of almost no value in this device
wouldn't it be fun I say to myself if I
had a device it needn't be much bigger
than this where I could be reading the
text in one language and listening to
the translation in another language and
maybe I'd be reading the language I know
better and listening to it in the
language I know less well or vice versa
I'd like to do that on a train sometime
I'd like to do that in lots of places
some time with the text & translation
lined up with each other just carefully
can't do it with this device maybe
someday you will be able to it's
probably likely that these devices will
evolve in competition by offering new
kinds of services but at the moment this
one the other ones that are out there
the other ones that people are talking
about have selected a form of reading
which is limited and old-fashioned and
of widespread social consumption value
people know how to sit down with a cheap
paperback and turn the pages from the
beginning to the end and call that
reading a book that is reading a book
there are many more things in the world
that can be reading a book I thought
when I sat down to do this that I would
be telling you with some venturesome
pneus about what kinds of reading i
could imagine that you might do with
this I'm just too obtuse to do yet but
I'm sure there are people who are doing
them I can't find any I can't think of
any that means I need to spend some time
in the next weeks and months paying
attention to what other people do there
probably are things that you can do with
this device that I haven't thought of
yet but none of them are presenting
themselves to me none of them are making
me aware of possibilities in reading
that I didn't know before as I was
getting off the train this afternoon I
said
realized what book I had almost been
thinking of all the way through the time
I've been working on this talk and
that's a relatively recent title by the
french scholar pierre by yard this is
the man who wrote the book called who
killed Roger Ackroyd in which he
explains to you who really killed Roger
Ackroyd in the Agatha Christie novel of
called the murder of Roger Ackroyd it's
an important work of literary criticism
the only problem is he still doesn't
know who really killed Roger Ackroyd I'm
the one who knows who really killed
Roger Ackroyd and they're both wrong by
art is an inventive literary scholar
however as that indicates his most
recent book is called how to talk about
books you haven't read the title was
designed to get exactly that giggle from
you most of the reviews that have been
in journals and magazines are by people
who are giggling while they write the
review it's actually a very serious book
but one of the most interesting books of
literary criticism I read in a long time
about our reading practices the way some
of our reading practices consist of how
we have read a book that we read five
years ago or 30 years ago and we've read
it and we can talk about it and we know
about it but what we're remembering is
just a small subset of what we have
remembered and what we have done I found
myself I say getting off the train in
New Haven wishing the Pierre by art had
invented the Kindle rather than Jeff
Bezos and I think finally tools leave
traces and inventors leave traces on
their tools and I think that's probably
the last thing that I learned I've had
the suspicion for many years looking at
a variety of computer products that have
been developed at the great secret of
modern time is that Steve Jobs can't
type if Steve Jobs could type I argue
then his company would have produced far
fewer devices that are so maddeningly
frustrating to use for those of us who
have ten fingers and fewer people would
be stabbing touch screens with one
finger at a time trying to create words
out of doing that my discovery from this
device at the end of the day is that I
come away with a sneaking suspicion that
in the ways in which i've talked about
reading the forms of reading that i
think are possible and desirable the
forms of reading that this kind of
building as a temple of reading was
designed to facilitate and invent
foster and continue when you talk about
real reading I think it may make sense
at the end to say the Jeff Bezos
probably doesn't really like to read
either that's too bad for him for the
device and for those of us who are
trying to make some sense out of the
device as we go back to our reading so
my last prop is of course another form
of Kindle this is from the universal
bibliothèque una voz eyelid bibliothèque
of the reklam publishing house in
germany it has the latin and german of
letters of cicero to Atticus on facing
pages this goes well on the train as
well you'll see it's even more compact
and you can spend a lot of time in this
volume almost as much as you can and one
of these devices so far this hasn't
killed that thank you